a lot of emotions going on and I think
just you and tell you about it
I didn't think that I was going to hit
me this hard until a justice
Oh
people up there
Oh fine
my name is ana gabriela Velasquez I was
born in Guatemala and my brothers and I
came to the States
1980 I identify myself as um wata Malin
Salvadorian and American one of the
reasons why my dad left wat Amala was
because there wasn't a future for us
there wasn't a future for him for my mom
for my brothers for myself my dad made
the decision of us coming to the States
he left when I was about six months
because he wanted to get stability so
then once he had that he was able to
have my mom come and then after it was
just a difficult process for us because
it was three of us we basically had to
cross the border we were all separated
for a very long time because of the
circumstances I want people to know that
it's hard you know it's hard it's not
easy being a US citizen means to me is I
don't have to worry or stress about
other things that people don't really
realize that's there I'm not gonna have
to do that anymore and I don't have to
worry about people asking me for extra
paperwork you could say
it's just more empowering knowing that
hey I can vote I can make a change just
having that opportunity just to be able
to come and do that and actually know
that I can do more for myself then I
would have been able to if I was back in
Guatemala please join me in welcoming
1148 new citizens
congratulations everyone this is I have
no words right
and it just really makes me think of all
the hard work that my parents had to go
through I don't know and it's just a
very proud day for me
I won't people to know is we're all
immigrants
nobody's from here my parents they
wanted a better education for myself
just like I'm pretty sure most parents
would want for their children